so as you all know IBM developed deep
blue in 1996 deep blue lost to Gary
Kasparov but they they did some
modifications and in 1997 as everybody
in here knows they they beat him and he
wasn't happy about it
Kasparov said they cheated and something
we'll talk about our first participant
in the panel is a computer scientist at
IBM's TJ Watson Research Center Sirius
chess competitor with a doctorate in
computer science he was one of the
brains behind the development of deep
blue from the beginning please welcome
Marie Campbell Noreen Campbell have a
seat and our next participant broke the
record as the youngest US national
master of chess at the age of 13 he's
older than that now he went on to
achieve the rank of Grandmaster won the
US Championship three times and was the
official Grandmaster consultant to the
IBM blue team please welcome Joel
Benjamin Thank You Joel
have a seat we have our water here so
let me let me start with you Marie at
what point in the development of deep
blue did you first see the fetal
sonogram yes well we I never actually
got to have a conversation with with
deep blue it was always strictly chess
moves
unlike well that experience we just went
it's actually quite comforting so tell
us about your impressions of the movie
what was realistic what was I think we
know what wasn't realistic but what what
rang true to you from your experience I
mean you did 11 of these tournaments and
you euro and your team and your
programming won eight of them yeah
so I when I first saw this I said this
it really visually rang true the
director obviously did a tremendous
amount of work to recreate the feeling
of this was a probably around 1980 81 or
so my first event was actually 1985
so a few years after this but it felt
true and then of course it got off the
tracks a little bit in terms of realism
but the conversations about AI
artificial intelligence the the role of
computer chess the military applications
were even discussed all of these things
ran very true to me and as a chess
player what was the feeling back then
about computers playing chess okay well
if we're talking about 1980 they're
actually at that time they were starting
to have some some some decent programs
there was a master level program at that
time called Bell and I played it in a
tournament and it gave me a very
unexpectedly difficult game but then I
managed to win because I just sort of
maneuvered around and it thought it had
the advantage and decided it had to win
somehow so eventually it did something
to worse in its position just to make
something happen and then I was able to
take control but it was we were just
starting to understand that there were
some computers that that could play
reasonably well but they're just a
handful of them presumably within a
short period after that the computer
wouldn't have fallen for that well they
started to make progress in those areas
and got sterile steadily better as the
years passed by so this was pretty
obvious but let's get into some details
what what did it mean when IBM got into
the game I mean obviously changed
everything well there was a group of
graduate students at Carnegie Mellon
University in Pittsburgh which I was one
that began sort of on the side working
on computer chess building machines and
there was a couple of very strong
machines that came out of out of
Carnegie Mellon in those days
both had at one point or another won the
tournament the equivalent of the
tournament that we just saw in the movie
and by the time
the late 80s rolled around our machine
called deep thought
named after Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy deep thought incidentally for
those who don't know deep thought was
built to answer the ultimate question
and the answer was 42 course nobody ever
knew what the question was so it was
this difficult challenge so at this
point deep thought became the first
computer to defeat a grandmaster in
tournament play and I think this
attracted IBM's attention they realized
this this was a way to illustrate the
progress and technology the advances in
parallel processing supercomputers by
building the next generation and that's
started the deep-blue project you told
me before the evening began that there
were kind of a cyclical series of
predictions that you know computers
would never win computers are going to
win tomorrow computers now they're never
going to win and we go back and forth it
has been very interesting how the
perceptions have changed over time so
nowadays everybody thinks oh yeah chess
is a very easy game because computers
are in fact superhuman nobody can
realistically expend expect to win a
match against a computer but in the
earliest days in the late 40s when
computers were just getting started the
thought was computers were a grand
challenge that getting a computer to
play chess would be fantastic even just
10 years later a Nobel Prize winner herb
Simon predicted that a computer would be
world champion within 10 years but then
about 10-12 years later they were saying
a world champion that science fiction
it's never going to happen
and then a few later they're saying yeah
it's within 10 years and pretty soon by
97 you know 40 years after the first
prediction it finally came true and herb
Simon was your thesis adviser he was on
my thesis committee on your committee
okay so 96 deep-blue at this point is
playing Kasparov and he wins and what do
you do
you bring in Joel for one thing and what
else do you do to beef it up so that in
97 you actually win the point made in
the movie was that brute force was an
important part of computers and in the
in the 80s it definitely was brute force
was almost everything the faster the
computer you had the better it was and
we had an element of that in deep blue
we made it much faster than any other
computer that was out there
200 million calculations per second per
second 200 million chest position router
second which is even more but we had
that but we had that more or less in in
96 when we lost we doubled that speed
doubling sounds like a lot but it's not
that much you just buy more but we also
increase the chest knowledge with the
help of grandmasters like Joel we
increase the chest knowledge and just
the general tournament awareness the
opening preparation things like that in
order to be ready what did you think
when they asked you to come in
well I think the way I got started was
kind of interesting because first I came
in to play Test matches and I had always
been very good playing against computers
there was an annual competition called
the Harvard Cup which was man versus
machine and I had won in two years in a
row so I thought okay this should be fun
you know I I was up for the challenge
and I went in there and I won two games
I won the first game in the second game
I could have made a draw anytime I
wanted but if I okay let me squeeze that
let me see what I could get and you know
I I did get the win and I think I will I
also helped teach them an awful lot
about the program and they realized that
you know was better to have me on their
side so they offered me this job which
they had mentioned that there was this
possibility that to come and train the
computer I thought this is a remarkable
she didn't know it was really an
audition right uh and the interview the
fact that he was so professional about
it and played it out all the way to the
end and showed he gave was the maximum
information was a sign that we wanted to
joël with us can you tell us about
anything that the more general audience
will actually be able to grab her yes
well my impression was at that point in
computer chess computer programmers were
really they were trying as Mary said
speed speed speed more calculations the
technical things and it was just kind of
accepted that computers would make
computer moves they would make ugly
moves they would fail to understand
strategy that not just a grandmaster but
even let's say an a level a human player
would understand style they yeah
computer certainly didn't really have
style they they didn't have knowledge
and it was I think it was just sort of
accepted and that was a big difference
that by bringing me in and my job was
really just to play all day long and
make observations and every time I saw
something said mmm this is an ugly move
I would write it down and you know make
these notes that I go to Murray and we
could talk about and we see if we could
fix it and when the when the match
actually happened in New York and there
was just so much talk about everything
and the thing that we kept hearing was
computers don't do that we were doing
things computers don't do well we did
things computers didn't do because we
made an attempt to fix them to change
things and the the rest of the computer
chess community was not prepared for
that you won the US National
Championship in 97 I did and that that
was a few months after the match and
there was no question about it it was
because of the work that that I did at
IBM because I was I was working at chess
you know 40 40 hours a week I had you
know good equipment to work with and I
was so focused and also by the end of
that experience I was so hungry to play
because I had been doing all that work
and very little playing so that actually
came back and helped me in a big way but
there's one interesting point in the
experience that we had with a Joel
there's something that's been
known in the area of artificial
intelligence for for four decades really
it's something called the knowledge
bottleneck and the idea is there's all
this knowledge in our heads and if we
want to program a computer to perform at
a high level in any task chess or
anything the idea was get the
information out of our head and into the
computer but there's this bottleneck
this funnel because the languages are so
different it's very difficult to get
that knowledge through into the computer
and programmed in and certainly when
when Joel first joined us we had that
experience Joel would say something that
to me as a chess player I wasn't
anywhere near the chess players as Joel
was but I was a reasonable player and it
made perfect sense to me but it wasn't
operational by that I mean it isn't
anything that we could have turned into
computer code so we had to Train Joel to
speak more like a computer in a sense
and I think he figured out what he could
tell us that was useful and what we just
throw up her hands and say we can't do
anything about that and I think we
changed him what you talked to us
throughout the course of the the event
right you didn't really expect with deep
thought and then maybe the early deep
blue.the kind of public reaction that
this drew well we actually full
disclosure we played deep thought
against Kasparov in 1989 also and he won
very easily at that point okay but it
made the front page of the New York
Times it the fact that we were playing
against the world champ there was in
Nova episode on that so I think that was
something that kind of public
fascination with this kind of event made
IBM pay attention as well so in 97 when
you're playing against Kasparov
something unexpected happens toward the
end of the first game of the six-game
match and he wins the game
but the computer did something a little
strange and it seems to have affected
the course of the whole rest of the
match well that's that's debatable um I
I think I've told this story to Nate
silver and it appeared in his book and
since then
Kasparov spokesperson has has denied
that it affected the match who knows but
the story is that at the end of that
first game deep blue was losing as you
said and it was about to make a move a
reasonable move that would have dragged
on the game for perhaps 15 more moves
maybe 20 more moves and at the last
second for no apparent reason it played
a completely different move random move
at rookie 8 yeah it was a terrible news
yeah and we resigned the game
immediately and so the game's over
according to an article that appeared on
the Internet
shortly afterwards the the Kasparov team
went back to their hotel room and
analyzed this position and Kasparov
asked the question how could a computer
play a move like that it's so terrible
and they did this incredibly deep
analysis and discovered that if you look
deeply enough into the position every
move loses every moves to force
checkmate and so it was seeing all the
way to the end of the game and realized
it didn't matter what it played so it
played a random move so this was pretty
far from the truth it could look a long
way but nowhere near that far so they're
seeing a conspiracy where they're seeing
a program that they don't have a good
model of how strong it really is right
and in that lack of a good model maybe
effects decisions later in the match I
think it was a fundamental problem that
that they felt they needed
understand everything that happened
instead of I mean Kasparov just needed
to play chess his handlers needed to
kind of get out of the way and let him
play and if he gets loses his focus get
him back focused again and for some
reason they didn't do that he had a
computer expert I'm sure that Fredrik
free Dell has seen bugs in the program
before I don't know why he didn't just
say it's a bug that's what most people
would do but for some reason everything
that happened they they had to interpret
it some way they had to understand it
and I think that made it impossible for
Kasparov to play his best chess he was
just allowing himself to be too
distracted he never really played his
normal game he certainly didn't play his
normal game he claimed that he had felt
he had to play this way because he
couldn't predict the way that that deep
blue was going to play which sounds fair
to me if he's playing against a human
he's he's going to get surprises too but
he felt that this this sort of anti
computer strategy was the right way to
go and it it worked on in some places
and didn't work in some other places and
that was that was kind of the bed that
he made to Lyon and allegedly at some
point he thought because he knew you
were on the team he thought he might be
playing you and it was a it was a Turk
situation no no it didn't have anything
to do with me it was back to the point I
said before everything had to be
understood and their team was thinking
two things at the same time a computer
there are these things computers can't
do and there are these things that they
always get right and if they get them
get them wrong than that then that's
suspicious so when it did good things it
wasn't supposed to do or did bad things
it wasn't supposed to do it was
suspicious basically every move that the
blue made was to them suspicious so it
was almost impossible to get through a
match without so they were not getting a
higher annoyed state throughout the
match well it to be fair though
Kasparov's
approach to the match I think if you
asked any Grandmaster today nowadays
with computers being so strong how would
you approach playing a computer I don't
think they would approach it by playing
their normal play chess I think they
would get just wiped off the board they
would try and play an anti computer
style as best they could and I know joel
has had experience trying to do this as
well and and I think it's a reasonable
was a reasonable decision to play an to
computer maybe it was wrong maybe it was
right but I think was a reasonable
decision okay so he wins the first game
deep blue wins Game two the next three
games or draws and then it's the last
game of the match and the matches on the
line and it's a very fast game yeah we
we've have many theories about what what
happened that game I think that the most
frequently quoted theory is that the
Kasparov team had decided that computers
of the day didn't handle a certain
opening very well and that probably deep
blue will not be able to handle that
opening very well and so it was played
it's an incredibly risky opening it was
an opening you would not play in because
part would never think about playing
against another person and in fact deep
blue handled it extraordinarily well I
think far as I could tell it played
perfectly in that game and we actually I
can't say that we anticipated that that
opening but in our preparation we tried
to to plug into in as many moves as we
could think of that we felt solid about
we could program it to play certain
moves in the opening beforehand so in
this particular opening this caro-kann
we basically put in okay if it plays
this we make this night sacrifice and
then I put in like one or two more moves
and I said okay
it can handle it from there so it played
it play it shot out the night sacrifice
instantly because that was
pre-programmed not because we actually
thought
that was going to happen we were just
you know tying up loose ends so we put
that move in which maybe was a shock
that it came so fast and but then it was
playing on its own right after that and
within two moves it understood that it
had a clear advantage so it was already
way above all the other computer
programs that didn't understand the
position at all how do you know that it
knows it has oh because it well because
it it shows the evaluation right I
really they were asking he was asking
connect and I get a valuation I see
though that's yeah yeah we would have
the evaluation we would have that
information that after each move you
have a percentage of your likelihood of
well it is based basically it just gives
a number and roughly speaking you know
like one point is a pawn so it's it
thought it was like the equivalent of
two pawns up even when it was
technically speaking down a knight so it
understood if you will started off
closer to equal and moved up yeah but
pretty quickly yep it it felt if we if I
can use that word that it had a very
good position better not you said we're
after yeah that's enough to find exactly
the right verb to use her computer so
the match is just over an hour and he
resigns when in a very surreal way by
the way he stood up and started talking
to his mother was she there yeah oh good
that would be worrisome yeah hmm so
that's it that's encouraging so um heap
ordinarily he would have drawn that game
right well did he have a positioned I
don't know he know he never because he
did this that this this this gamble
right out of the okay I'm thinking of a
different game okay now if he had played
to steer the game into a draw and made
it you know it would have been a drawn
match if that had happened and obviously
history would have been very different
right um
what do you think the effect was on him
to be the first human to the first world
champion - well for one thing he went on
to set a new ratings record and became
in retain his World Championship for
several years athlete he was severely
damaged yeah you know he took it hard
but you know he always had a remarkable
resiliency he could bounce back from
things he was whatever other experience
we had with him he was incredibly good
chess player just remarkably talented so
yeah he went on to you know bigger and
better things and you know this will not
be the only thing that he's remembered
for now that the youngest world champion
holding the world championship title for
many many years so let's talk about the
legacy of deep blue deep blue was
retired he's on a stud farm somewhere in
Kentucky
Smithsonian excellent Watson was the
next big the computer that played
Jeopardy was the next big artificial
intelligence public display yes what did
deep blue contribute to that because
it's a whole different set of problems
it is I didn't work on Watson I didn't
work directly on Watson I think it's
it's the next stage in the progression
of advancing the area of artificial
intelligence deep blue played a game of
chess which is as they were saying 64
squares somewhat limited in that sense
even though there's a astronomical
number of possible games it's all very
constrained you know what moves are
possible you know what the goal is when
you get to a game like Jeopardy you've
opened it up to all human language and
it's not just simple straightforward
questions but but puns and jokes and all
of the the quirks of human language so
being able to deal with language was the
next next level beyond I think in a way
deep blue is giving a preview of what
we're
going to see in many other fields over
the coming decades as computers start
off laughably bad and they get better
and better you can see that in this in
the movie that the master who played at
the end was very smug and superior about
his attitude and not so smug towards the
end but I think I saw that through all
the levels of players the players would
say at say at the expert level oh well
computers can beat the a-class players
but they'll never beat the experts and
then they beat the experts and the
Masters say well they can beat them but
they can't beat me and went all the way
on to Kasparov and now everybody
acknowledges that they are super super
human the question is you know the what
I mentioned before the knowledge
bottleneck now that they're superhuman
how do they teach us how can we learn
from them and I think that's a pretty
much unsolved problem and we'll be
seeing that in these other areas where
programs get stronger and stronger at
solving particular kinds of problems how
do they get the information and
knowledge back to the human beings and
it's quite an interesting and difficult
problem from you know the molecular
biology question of protein folding I
mean that's really interesting if the
computers can figure it out and then
show the molecular biologists what
they're doing I mean it opens up a whole
new dimension or medal right yeah
absolutely yes so what are you both up
to now I'm still a research scientist at
IBM I'm looking at problems in what
we're calling smarter work force that's
understanding all the factors that go
into the people in a work force and
using the analytics the analysis type
approaches that we're looking at here to
get people working together more
collaboratively more efficiently taking
advantage of all the new data about
people on social networks so it's the
goal is to just make people more
collaborative I'm mostly teaching chess
in schools and private students I'm
married I have two young children four
and two so that takes up a lot of my
time and consequently don't get to play
much anymore but last month I got to
play in the u.s. championship for the
26th time that's that is a record and I
and I managed to imagine to tie for
sixth out of the field of 24 and I
looked around and notice that this year
I was the fourth oldest player in the
field after you know so many years being
one of the youngest players so now as
one of the old players I showed okay I
know I still I still got it can still
play so I'm I think I'm going to keep
trying to play at least a little bit for
as long as I can next year you're
eligible to play senior level yeah
believe it or not yet because in chess
seniors is defined as 50 so I was
looking for the senior title yeah and
your mother is in the senior tournament
currently yeah well she took a bite to
come here get sushi he's a oh no she's
out there you can end the way Kasparov
ended well let's let's give a big round
of applause to thank thank you Lori
Campbell Joel Benjamin very much good
night
there were